I feel like I'm gonna get stumped
it's like bad version of a [ __ ] stamp
Trump's I mean that has to be Democrat I
feel like all of those words are too big
for Trump it's too long-winded to be
Trump it's got to be Democrat I know it
was a Bernie sander that said it I'm
gonna go with Trump considering his
ideology I have to go Democrat oh yeah
what so he's over there thinking now
oh he's pandering he's a flip-flopper he
doesn't mean this that is true it's just
really absolutist obi-wan says that only
cysts deal in absolutes I said Lord I'm
gonna have to also say it's burn man I'm
gonna go with my gun I'm gonna disagree
I'm gonna say that it's this oh we're
all getting AIDS on this test I want to
say this again but I'm worried I'm gonna
be wrong does Donald Trump even know
women exist I feel like that's not a
Hillary because she's not using like we
Hillary Hillary you all know just say
Trump
hahahaha lover girl
well doesn't want women to have anything
he doesn't like being interviewed by
them he doesn't like periods
the syntax of that sentence sounds very
trumpet is used to your fire reported
this is so hard
there's a lot harder than if I were
gonna be 100% Hillary me I think it's
Hillary it's literally damning if he
said it so I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
Trump because I'm confused now I'm gonna
go get traffic Trump what oh he likes me
she likes my people mommy more though I
feel like Trump wouldn't think that
critically about the different people in
society I think he just makes grandiose
statements terrorist is a fear mongering
word it's not a brainy words you know
say is that a village it's still a trick
gonna have to say chop Donald Trump damn
it
if he said that I'm impressed because
where has that been is definitely much
fun that to me has got to be Hillary's
grand enhan okay fine
what I feel like a lot of Trump
supporters today would not get behind a
lot of the statements that were his
politics is just a game Donald Trump was
just like you know what now I play this
game too like you guys I feel like we're
fighting against the Trump of today
which is the ridiculous punch everyone
in the face Trump and the Trump of
yesterday they're two completely
different people
it's Jekyll and Hyde